[Música]
[Aplausos]
detrás
del arco iris
al final
hay un
[Música]
de sueños que se hacen realidad
detrás del arco iris
ya verás
hay un cielo tan puro y una canción
ah
cuántas veces les dijeron que no en la
vida
cuántas veces les dijeron que no el año
pasado
cuántas veces les dijeron que no hoy
cuántos tipos de no conocen
[Música]
bueno yo hoy voy a hablar de tres tipos
de heno que seguramente a casi todos los
que estamos aquí presentes o por lo
menos a mí si es que nos han atravesado
en algún momento de la vida mi nombre es
adrián sorrentino soy actor soy cantante
soy bailarín no sé si lo hago bien pero
le pongo onda
y empecé a los cinco o seis años
vocacionalmente y luego después de los
diecisiete años profesionalmente
nací en una familia de empresarios de
una clase bastante acomodada para los
que el arte era solo para ser observado
como espectador pero casualmente en casa
había un piano un piano de cuarta cola
que basta saber cómo había llegado a
casa
que mis hermanas de vez en cuando en
alguna fiesta o en algún cumpleaños
alguna fiesta de año nuevo navidad un
domingo aporreaban de oído o porque
habían tocado de vez en cuando alguna
clase
recuerdo que tenía 5 o 6 años estaba en
la primaria y una vecina llamada sandra
sandra rivas
nos invitó a todos los chicos del barrio
a participar de unos talleres que ella
iba a dar en el garage de su casa en
aquel momento se usaba mucho dar clases
de alcaraz si había muchas academias de
danza en los garages
bueno por lo menos recuerdo que nos
llamó por teléfono no a nosotros sino a
nuestras madres y nuestras madres bueno
dijeron vamos a mandar a los chicos a
danza había dos posibilidades una era
flamenco y la otra era tap que en aquel
momento se le decía a zapatero americano
también se le dice claqué que es esa
danza que se hace con este tipo de
zapatitos que tienen chapitas
si este por supuesto que les voy a
bailar un poquito porque si no me van a
matar
y recuerdo que empecé a bailar tap en el
garage de la casa de la señorita sandra
qué alegría más grande descubrir un
universo que en el fondo yo sabía que a
futuro me iba a marcar en ese momento ya
me modificó y estuvimos todo un año todo
un año completo ensayando sudando
corriendo yendo o viniendo practicando
equivocándonos mejorando lo que sabíamos
en puliéndolo porque se acercaba el fin
de año construyendo nuestros vestuarios
nuestros saquitos poniendo las
lentejuelas nuestro sombrerito de
cascaritas nuestros bastones pintando
los blancos mal no importa pero con
mucho amor y mucha pasión y llegó el
momento de la presentación
fin de año y siempre lo recuerdo
claramente teatro independencia a la
casa mayor del arte mendocino llenas
repleta de espectadores casi 900 y yo
una cosa así bueno ahora no soy
muchísimo más alto creer pero una cosita
así parado antes de que se abriera el
telón con un miedo pero con una emoción
muy grande se abrió el telón y se me
número y la gente me ovacionó me
aplaudió y ese aplauso y esa ovación y
ese amor a raudales lo guardé en mi
corazón
recuerdo que luego nos cambiamos en el
camarín y a la salida
subo al auto mi padre gira y me dice
hijo estuvo muy bonito lo que hiciste
pero te voy a pedir por favor que no lo
vuelvas a hacer nunca más en tu vida fue
el primero que recibí como un cachetazo
pero es cachetazo se formó
automáticamente porque yo en ningún
momento le di entidad a ese no porque
fue tanto el amor que recibí esa noche
de gente que no me conocía fue tanta la
alegría que recibí fue fue tanto
la cantidad de comentarios que la gente
hizo sobre lo que había hecho ese
corchito de un metro veinte que ese no
que me dijo mi padre desapareció
totalmente por supuesto que seguir
bailando seguir bailando a escondidas a
escondidas porque si mi padre se
enterara se armaba
no tenía el dinero para hacerlo así que
mi abuela me pasaba escondida unos
dinerillos y mi madre otros y yo a
escondidas seguía yendo con la señorita
sandra y luego con la señorita nin y ya
cuando fui más grande me fui a buenos
aires nueve años y después cuatro años a
nueva york y hoy sigo siendo un este
bailarín de tap y sigo dando clases de
tap
a pesar del no de mi padre y ahora debe
bailar un poquito
un fake
gracias
las cosas las cosas que generan los no
verdad
estoy bailando está aquí es increíble
que mágica es la vida tan mágica que
después llegó el teatro después llegó el
teatro y me acuerdo que estábamos en
unas vacaciones y mi primo ariel me
contó adri o sabes que me ha notado en
un curso preparatorio de la escuela de
teatro de la universidad nacional de
cuyo hay que hacer un casting para saber
si entramos y yo por seguirlo a él claro
me anoté también no sentía tanta empatía
con el teatro pero
algo de pasión había en mi interior y
mucha curiosidad y me presenté me fui me
fui a presentar al casting de la palabra
de está en ese entonces era y fuimos los
dos juntos la escuela de teatro estaba
en la calle sant sarmiento y 25 de mayo
donde ahora está el vestuario de la
universidad nacional de curso
llegamos éramos más o menos 120 alumnos
teníamos que quedar 20 más o menos por
el grupo por aula y bueno todos rendimos
el casting y al final nos pusieron a
todos en semicírculo éramos más o menos
150 120 cuerdo pero éramos muchísimos y
uno a uno todos juntos lo que me pareció
terriblemente cruel porque la verdad es
que nos podrían haber llamado aparte y
decirnos mira la verdad estuvo muy bien
la verdad estuvo muy mal o si ser vivo
no servís pero no fue ahí adelante de
todo un escrache total y nos fueron
diciendo uno a uno
vos services lo tuyo brillante excelente
lo tuyo maravilloso hijo
realmente tienes un talento
impresionante cuando llego a mí me dice
vos
no servís realmente no tienes no tenéis
pasta de artista no la tenéis no la teme
pero pero me dijo por lo menos dijo pero
visto cuando a veces pero pero claro te
vamos a dejar que te quedes como oyente
qué aburrimiento nos dice que es
preferible ir a tomar un helado a la
esquina y pensar bueno pero me quedé me
quedé como oyente y sentadito ahí los
veía que saltaban que gritaban que
saltaban corrían venían caminaban como
si fueran monstruos caminaban como si
fueran árboles caminaban como si fueran
pájaros
y en una cosa impresionante y yo sentado
mirando qué triste es a la mía pero
fíjate cómo son las cosas que ocurrió
algo mágico porque si no es magia esto
no sé qué es
empezó un paro un paro de 90 días
no es común en la argentina que suceda
pero ocurrió a un paro de 90 días 90
días tres meses claro los alumnos
desaparecieron dijeron paros todos pero
yo me enteré por una vecina que los
profesores de teatro no habían adherido
fíjate voz y seguían yendo porque tenían
que cumplir su horario
y allá fui yo
hola soy el oyente
me pueden dar clases a mí solo
así
[Risas]
y me dieron me tuvieron que dar más así
que pasé de ser oyente a ser el único
alumno
tuve maestros particulares durante 90
días y terminé siendo el protagonista de
una obra de teatro de alejandro
sieveking que se llama animas de vida
claro que tú
[Aplausos]
bueno y esa pasión esa pasión que
despertaron esos maestros sigue viva
hasta el día de hoy si ese no que me
dijo esa maestra es bueno sirvió para
que se le pusiera onda caradurez que
fuera con 13 años a decirle de mezclas a
mí solo éste
esa pasión la refresco y la revivo cada
día que me meto al camarín preparo mis
cosas yo soy de los obsesivos que llega
a tres obras antes al teatro es este y
este año me tocó en suerte me tocó en
suerte hacer un personaje adorable un
personaje en una obra que se llama
porque la voy a seguir haciendo por
supuesto por eso la pongo un presente
todavía porque no la voy a dejar de
hacer el eunuco una obra en la que hago
de meretriz una señora meretriz española
y cada vez que me preparo y me maquillo
para darle vida a ese personaje que está
en un papel sí por los personajes viven
en un papel hasta que un artista los
toma este cada vez que me maquillo
pienso en todo el tiempo que paso y
pienso en ese no y cómo se pulverizó sí
tengo la suerte de estar haciendo
estatales que hablas y que es un español
muy mirón
seductora tal vez
hola qué tal
mi nombre estáis
cómo estáis
dado que como estáis vosotros no
que como estáis que como soy yo por lo
general me dicen chula majagua para a
ver ponerle un poquito de actitud espera
que yo pregunté
ahora voy a preguntar y cómo estáis
allá atrás también pueden participar no
he escuchado ningún piropo por allí es
atrás
gracias muchas gracias ahora sí cómo
estáis vosotros
y alegría más grande bueno a esas cosas
que a mí me encanta y esa pasión me hace
seguir hasta el día de hoy siendo actor
disfrutando la actuación poder disfrutar
el juego que me permite la actuación y
poder seguir dando clases y luego luego
llegó el canto me enteré que los
profesores de canto habían llegado a
mendoza
principalmente por el problema de salud
de uno de ellos que era asmático
entonces les recomendaron que vinieran a
vivir a mendoza y me enteré que estaban
aquí y me fui a tomar clases de canto y
en el camino apareció el tercer no de mi
vida que fue el peor el peor y el más
grave que fue el mío propio me iba
diciendo no no voy a poder yo no puedo
cantar yo no voy a cantar solo nuestro
lo mío lo mío no al cantar a ver si te
puedo bailar sí te puedo actuar por
cantar no cantar no cantar no cantar no
llegué a la clase para que la clase me
empezaron a hacer vocalizar cuando yo
sentí el piano sentí que empezaba el
exorcismo por qué
empecé a sudar me temblaban las manos me
puse rojo las venas hinchadas me faltaba
que me girará la cabeza apretaba los
glúteos las rodillas no sabía qué hacer
la mandíbula me titulaba el rostro sólo
unos minutos era una cosa terrible lo
que me pasó claro después muchos años
después cuando me he vuelto profesor de
canto me enterado que el cantar es una
de las cosas más difíciles para el ser
humano si es una forma muy compleja y
cuando termino mi vocalización o mi
exorcismo como quieren llamarle mi
maestro alberto me dijo adrián realmente
tiene muchísimo potencial te tomo como
alumno y me quedé como alumno y sigo
siendo alumno de él hace casi 30 años
este dios le de mucha vida más a alberto
porque la verdad es que siempre está
bueno hacerse un refresh en la garganta
y sigo disfrutando de cantar sigo
disfrutando de cantar porque me parece
que es una de las formas más exquisitas
de ejercer la libertad
además el que canta a los demonios
espanta y no solamente sigo cantando
sino que además sigo dando clases de
canto y tengo mis alumnos que son muy
felices de cantar también hay que
hay que bailar a pesar de los no de la
familia
que actuar a pesar de los no de la
sociedad y hay que cantar a pesar de los
no de uno mismo
toda mi vida me hicieron creer que el
arte era un monstruo pestilente al que
había que perseguir atrapar y matar
yo en el fondo de mi corazón siempre
supe que no era así pero lo he
perseguido perseguido ese monstruo
pestilente que es el arte hasta el día
de hoy lo sigo persiguiendo y lo voy a
seguir persiguiendo y el día de mañana
el día de mañana cuando ya mi aliento no
me pertenezca a mí y le corresponda a
otra persona que no necesite mucho más
me voy a encontrar con el monstruo
y le voy a decir
o la pestilente
cómo estás
qué bueno que estés bien de perseguir de
perseguir toda la vida
y aquí estamos juntos
pero te perseguir y te juro que no fue
para matarte te perseguí
para decirte gracias
muchas gracias
que su vida es a mi hombro
qué lindo la pasamos verdad
qué bien
qué lindo camino recorrido
brindemos
brindemos y brindemos mirando el
atardecer
detrás de cada no
ay
magníficos y maravillosos
detrás de cada no
ay
muchos deseos que uno tiene que cumplir
detrás de cada no
hay un pensamiento que uno tiene que
tener
que es que si algo
está preparado para uno por más escollos
o trabas que haya en el camino
sucederá
si más allá del cielo azul
las aves vuelan
por qué no poder
bola
[Aplausos]